right now hunter biden's art business is
raising even more concerns about
possible
influence peddling on top of all we do
know
as hunter's uh dealer art dealer that is
now said back in 2015 he wanted to be
quote the lead guy in china
adding quote i plan to find and discover
and bring to the rest of the world
those i consider china's next generation
of modern
artists remember all these buyers they
will remain anonymous
they say that's ethical will any of the
buyers be connected to the
chinese government or military and i'll
ask again
what exactly is the market for these
paintings 500 grand
now we did reach out to hunter biden's
lawyer and the art dealer
his name is george burgess for comment
we've yet to hear anything here with the
reaction wisconsin senator ron johnson
sounds suspicious to me senator
especially in light of what you and
senator grassley
have already told us about
well it's highly suspicious sean you
know we
requested his travel records from the
secret service where hunter biden had
secret service protection for about five
and a half years during that time period
he made 70 trips overseas think about
that that's about a trip a month
and my question is what was he selling
you know most international business
people have a product or
a real service that they're selling you
know other than the biden family name
peddling influence what was hunter biden
doing of course this was before he
became
the 21st century picasso uh of course
now he's selling that artwork so no this
stinks to high heaven and
the only reason it's not getting more
scrutiny in the mainstream press
because the mainstream media is part and
parcel of the democratic party they're
the communication
arm of the democratic party they're
they're not going to even look at this
much less
be concerned about it yeah
you know but this is the thing if if
you're firing americans from
uh high paying keystone xl pipeline
jobs uh with the stroke of a pen but
you're giving a waiver to putin
and and you're given a meeting to putin
and they're involved in cyber attacks
and the
chinese are talking about well
reunification with taiwan
and we know the money that that hunter
biden made in china and made in
russia and made in kazakhstan and made
in
in ukraine uh why does this all
sound corrupt and what do you think
about the anonymous side of this
well it is corrupt and you know what's
what's even more concerning is just the
unequaled
administration of justice you know
because he's hunter biden uh
you know doesn't pay taxes on things
apparently and the irs and the
department of justice look the other way
how however if you're for example
affiliated with the last administration
you get a pre-dawn raid you know by a
swat team
or you get arrested and prosecuted for
being a foreign agent and you haven't
registered for it i wonder if
hunter by never registers a foreign
agent well how about his background
check
that secret service personnel apparently
tried to get those background check
uh information when he threw that or
when his girlfriend his sister-in-law
uh threw his gun away in that dumpster
nah and shawn this stinks to high heaven
and the american people understand that
the only people that don't understand
that is department of justice
and the news media you know
we really need you to stay on top of
this because
i think over time now the walls are
coming crashing down on the biden family
syndicate
and imagine if it was trump senator
thank you we appreciate the update
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else